wave of heavy selling rocked major stock
indexes around the world Friday's big
sell-off was driven by investors
concerns that the global economy could
fall into recession as the fed and other
central banks raise interest rates in an
effort to stop inflation the Dow Jones
Industrial Average the S P 500 Index and
the NASDAQ each lost more than one and a
half percent on Friday the Dow closing
at its lowest level since late 2020 and
the s p is down 23 percent since its
peak in January Michael George is here
with more on these troubling economic
Trends Michael what can you tell us well
Michelle good morning everyone's worried
about that one big word recession and a
lot of people think that's where we're
headed the interest rate hikes aimed at
cutting inflation are having a ripple
effect on the economy
[Applause]
at the New York Stock Exchange the
president of a company called
sustainable development Equity
officiated the close of what was a
terrible
486 Point drop day preceded by a
terrible week
and the Applause doesn't drown out the
fact that the market had dropped more
than 5 000 points in 12 months with more
than a thousand points lost this week
and there are more storm clouds ahead
according to UC Berkeley Economist James
Wilcox it's very likely that we are
going to have a recession and the
probabilities of that occurring have
been rising uh all year really and
especially since this summer with the
FED being so aggressive about raising
interest rates the Federal Reserve
board's Trio of 2022 interest rate hikes
has made borrowing harder for companies
that want to grow and for consumers
particularly those who hope to own a
home the average 30-year fixed mortgage
interest rates have spiked from 3.3 to
6.7 percent over the past nine months
thanks to the Federal Reserve board
hikes how much further mortgage interest
rates might go up uh is awfully hard to
know but I think we could still see some
other interest rates Auto rates credit
card interest rates uh moving up and
that'll make it more difficult for
people to buy new cars or to buy more
expensive cars at Cliff's Hardware in
San Francisco consumers weren't waiting
for credit card interest hikes trying to
see if we could go and eat out as much
because you can see a big increase on
that
also because it'll be more aware of how
much we spent in all of this at the
White House Press Secretary Kareem
Jean-Pierre addressed the economy
yesterday that is why we we passed that
is why Democrats in Congress passed info
inflation reduction act by the way no
Republicans supported that and the White
House also points to gas prices which
have fallen significantly over the last
few months and one part of the economy
that remains strong the job market
unemployment is at 3.7 percent Jeff
Michael thank you very much